Matt let's start with you because you
actually made your way through New York
City and your big what Ford f-150 I got
a big Raptor here all-wheel drive with
35 inch wheels so I was well prepared
obviously most New Yorkers are very
poorly prepared for this kind of thing
even though it happens every winter
Betty it shouldn't be a surprise to us
by this point its nose during the winter
months and it's not really that big a
deal four to six inches apparently was
what we got overnight that's not really
very much snow although here in New York
City they still haven't managed to clear
the roads out where I live in
Westchester everything is pretty clear
and pretty dry out there already so i
guess the travel ban as you said it's
been lifted people are probably going to
start driving a little bit though a lot
of people have already taken off work a
lot of the travel a lot of the train
lines are still closed bus lines
obviously are still closed subway lines
are still closed so maybe this will just
be a snow day where people can go around
and do some shopping where is your
Raptor by the way can we can we turn
around and get a picture of my truck
here so I have you know concerns about
zombie attacks and doomsday prepping so
I i bought this big behemoth from alan
mulally last year and it works very well
in the snow a lot of people though i
noticed our driving around in two-wheel
drive cars still with summer tires or at
least not winter tires on and that's
really inadvisable in january during a
snowstorm so fortunately this travel ban
has taken a lot of other cars off the
road and i get a chance to go hooting
and my big rafter here uh yes and I'm
sure you were you were while being very
safe Matt also having a pretty good time
in that in that getup and that's that
was doing very safe doughnuts yeah I
think you just made his truck tax
deductible oh well there you go that's
right using it for work what side you
know we were this morning we all are
coming in we're walking we're trying to
figure out ways maybe trying to hitch a
ride here with Matt but uber I couldn't
help but notice
in this time of need was down in fact
you know this is what we saw on all of
our phones this morning our producers
and myself uber service well available I
did not know that yes and it's
interesting because you know they're
kind of known as the bad boy kind of a
little bit evil company and I think part
of the particle is that New York I think
I said you can't have surged go up more
than 26 or two point eight percent so
they did that and making donations to
the Red Cross so it's unfortunately
actually hate them I think they're
behaving themselves and I think they
were growing up as a company and it's a
good thing but what does that tell you
though I mean here at the moment that
people need their car yeah right
suddenly they're not available is that a
big hole in their business model here no
no it's interesting is yesterday whether
it was google express or instacart or
all of the convenience services i use i
trudged my way over to the whole foods
down the block which was jammed and
everyone said listen we really can't
handle this load so de Blasio shut down
subways and streets and in hindsight it
was more than had to happen but it was
it was playing it safe and I think that
any of these convenience demand services
its understanding right can't help with
a man like we was all supposed to be and
it's interesting cuz I get to look at on
I looked at in Lexington had like one in
the morning and it was empty and you
just that you never see that that's town
you know so the mayor said everybody
gets get some place and I think Oh bird
prep frankly wouldn't have had any
business right and they probably would
right exactly they would have had they
didn't exist an existing year or two ago
so it's you know it's like will live